yeah hello and welcome to this video
isn't commissaris lakdawala yeah that's
true it's very well known nowadays for
all his books his publishing books like
no tomorrow and he goes for the
Scandinavian poo not my not something
that I have studied already so I kind of
make things up here wow what a greedy
guy John but it's kind of understandable
it's not so easy here to to handle this
situation b2 is definitely hanging rook
be one looks extremely lame but I'm not
quite sure how I can sacrifice this
efficiently so let's go rupee one and
then see what happens but there is no
idea of the quite clearly but well how
bad can it be it's not not like I should
be worse here just centralized I'm
catching up a little bit on the clock
the Queen won't be too is still somewhat
weird i wonder what is about to do with
it I mean Bishop d7 is a move that who
isn't it a little bit tricky now for you
Queen where do you go where do you go
now
when do you go from dancin rollers right
yeah this Queen only has he fallen after
Bishop e2 its lights out so it has to
sacrifice the Queen so what's going on
here I'm a queen up hooray but you still
have to win and sometimes it's not so
easy what to do I think probably this
then try to utilize the beef our Bishop
a three i think i have c5 that should
should trap it oh that's not that such a
bad start hey I blundering this porn he
doesn't take it okay I'm threatening c4
I was threatening c4 so this is looking
nice the position opens up with a queen
you want the position usually to open up
and you want to try to get two positions
where the other side does not have a
good long-term peace placement so don't
want to give them outposts if possible I
just give an md5 I don't know if this is
a big deal down
it's so reasonably reasonably open ok ok
I mean this I can just cover 1c3 but how
to do it I would like to win this porn
quite clearly i wanna just get this
around I can also play a six maybe and
work to be seven that that also looks
quite good like this Queen a form to sex
what are you doing in I want to look on
the 737 s my idea
yeah I can tikz form if it takes a six
shouldn't shouldn't be bad always have
to watch our folder for the damn Forks
so go here and I'm threatening c4 here
oh it doesn't isn't that bad I still
have this pin so jigs takes Knight takes
rook e7 should-should enters black
resigns yeah the sound probably is a
little bit different I hope it is good
yeah this is not that much to to do here
in terms of analysis he just put his
Queen in a in a tight spot and then lost
it this is probably not the best way of
handling this opening I think g3 is
probably they go g3 after a six I'm kind
of really have no idea ya hear I don't
know maybe I can set the porn somehow
rupee one is a very meek move but I
didn't want to spend a long time him he
can of course grab grab this pawn it
said that's certainly playable I don't
think that this can be bad I could just
develop I have a little bit of
compensation but I doubt that this is
enough yeah I think here this looks
normal now more or less but then he
really am I mean the Queen already is a
little bit short of squares and this is
yeah this is putting it in real prune
real trouble yeah you should have
thought maybe in for a moment I'm not
playing Bishop c7 just for the heck of
it you can play this helped give away
the exchange
he has no no no compensation hear of any
serious kind but still that either the
Queen was lost I probably didn't play it
all that great but the queen is a queen
is a queen somehow yeah that's the story
of this game thanks for watching